20 seconds of darkness followed by a
full minute of 70 millimetres snowy
landscape porn look I like Quentin
Tarantino you probably like Quentin
Tarantino too but quitting Tarantino
likes quitting Tarantino more than we do
who gives us this is his eighth film
also you're backtracking through your
head and wondering why this is the
eighth then not the 9th because he
considers Kill Bill all one movie but we
still can't get Kill Bill as one movie
ok we can wait um just have no choice
so wait that wasn't even a church just a
random crucifix in the middle of nowhere
also I wouldn't even question this if
Tarantino didn't show it to me for 3
damn minutes waiting yeah for one moment
or Cui's think so be can hear him ask
this question slightly above a whisper
trying to bring a cup of no goods in the
market and by taking these no goods off
of his curb and putting them in the road
presumably so he has a place to sit
mark we screed unnecessary work for
himself damn blasted Blizzard has been
on our ass for the last three hours
and they're continuing to outrun it
Tarantino uses the term black fella for
more queefs in the scene because he's
saving up for another term he will later
use and accepts you take them to guns a
years and you lay them on that rock over
yonder Kurt Russell landed this role
based on his impression of John Wayne
okay boy we'll give it a try are we
supposed to believe that John Ruth is
some sort of kind-hearted Samaritan here
there's no way in hell he trusts warrant
and giving him a ride gives him
absolutely nothing maybe he knows
there's a plot later
Daisy must have a steel plate in her
head because after a hit like that I
don't think she could immediately get up
and start talking again
Tarantino his foot flesh has gone too
far or sport it hasn't been too long
since they were out the snow and I
assume their stagecoach doesn't have a
heater in it so they should still have
snow on their hats and jackets this
movie is so anti-littering mark we
Stroh's have recently lit still
potentially flammable match on the floor
of a wooden stage coat instead of
outside in the snow rains davanon like a
man
I know that Daisy is looking ahead to
when her family comes and tries to
rescue her but she has to know after all
the abuse she's taken she's going to get
punched by John every time she says
something like this right
what is her endgame for getting tortured
I am subjected to watching Daisy lick
blood off her face for 37 seconds
Quentin
you have any Oh Morricone at your
disposal and you'd rather play this
anachronistic pop song I'm gonna add
three sins for that either I've
underestimated mid 19th century
Wyoming's ability to plow snow or this
is simple you still got it John Ruth
plays the pronoun game so that Warren
has to ask what the hell it means and
this is just one of the letters knowing
what we find out later this so-called
Lincoln letter is a forgery
Lauren sure does go to prestige level
commitment when it comes to being
protective about it they was pen pals
John says that Lincoln and more Cui's
are pen pals even though that term was
coined in the late 1930s
mark we sponges Daisy out of the
stagecoach just at the right time so
that they can run into yet another
person who can help out with the plot
that view Chris Mannix Wyoming is a
pretty big place the likelihood of John
being two-for-two of knowing people he
runs into is pretty slim you're the
hangman bobrucz my lord is that really
the real head of major Marquess looking
at me now
and there's PT Barnum and Louisa May
Alcott so I'm supposed to freeze to
death cause you find something hard to
believe no I suppose not it seems like
John just had a stroke it's the only
thing I can think of that would explain
his sudden compassion for this guy he
doesn't seem to care for does he know
how famous you want well it's convenient
these characters don't know just enough
about each other for an explanation to
be necessary you ain't never heard a
well in bet president wall camped West
Virginia West Virginia was a union state
that broke away from Virginia because
those counties didn't want to be a part
of the Confederacy making it a key
border state for the Union which would
make having a Confederate prison or war
camp there highly unlikely even though
it's not impossible just kind of a bad
choice to put your fictional prison when
there are plenty of other Confederate
states to choose from you will because
when Bob walked out a bit ago it shot
just fine Tim Roth isn't Christoph Waltz
in this sink let's just say I don't like
cheating a hangman he got to make a
living - does the hangman get paid per
hang legitimately don't know it seems
like that would create a conflict of
interest we watched them do this in real
time for no reason other than Tarantino
has this seventy millimeter camera and
he's gonna use it goddamn it I prefer to
carry the rods and rope along with me
rather than go back and forth in a
blizzard either someone is trying to
make a bead curtain out of chains or I'm
just
completely ignorant as to why someone
would eat all those hanging there either
way I'm counting it as a city you'd
attract with it being conducted held it
does Oswaldo already know about maurices
Lincoln letter the only way he could
know is if Ruth somehow I told him about
it while they were off-camera for no
reason any sane person can think of Tim
Ralph did his character study by
watching Monty Python for several days
where the hell is this light coming from
there's a huge blizzard outside so it's
definitely not sunlight I guess Mindy
got a time machine travelling to the
Future brought floodlights back with her
and I thought poor taco Oh red apple
you're the thin thread that barely makes
all the Tarantino movies somehow part of
the same world is that general Sanford
Smithers I see there must be only like
20 people in all of Wyoming because
there's at least one person who has some
connection with a person they just met
which is very helpful when we the
viewers don't know who anyone is in the
first place respect
did he make Bruce Dern swallow gravel
for the state if the man a lozenge we
divide all inside and this is having a
Brit decide how we divide up geography
always leads to trouble
knives don't make ringing sounds as
they're pulled through the air I'm gonna
cut you loose wha whe mr. John's
suspicious of everyone roof over here
decides to uncuff Daisy because he's
overdue for a lapse in judgment comes
with some of them mean bastards out
there it's the only thing does the job
you really only need to hang mean
bastards but mean bastards you need this
is that classic Tarantino tell you like
it is style of dialogue but sometimes
Tarantino's dialogue is repetitive but
being repetitive is something
Tarantino's dialogue does sometimes I
don't know if tension is supposed to be
building right now but it feels more
like I'm watching a very boring episode
of frontier big brother John Abraham
this sums up the movie to me moments
masqueraded its tension but in reality a
repetitive issue but ain't nobody in
Minnie's haberdashery ever correspondent
with Abraham Lincoln you want to know
why I lie about something like that
white man got me on that stagecoach
didn't it did it though I thought it was
the agreement between you and John about
protecting your respective bounties but
that was so long ago now who the hell
knows young woman fevered cooker star
slash winner spenders wouldn't be caught
dead talking to a black person minutes
ago but now he shared personal details
about his left
boy in the middle of Wyoming hiding away
from a blizzard in a remote location
Warren runs into the father of a guy he
killed
it's interesting how Marquess and the
naked guy are able to be here then cross
the railroad tracks then end up where
they were originally and suddenly we're
next to this river Wyoming is a
confusing place he's just a sneaking
trying to get you to go for that gun
racism aside and he's right and for some
reason Smith Lewis doesn't take this
statement more seriously I pulled my big
black pecker
ID my pants there are two things that I
generally don't want to happen at the
same time when I go see a movie
Sam Jackson talked about his big black
pecker and the camera begins tilting
down as he does it this is a story of
general Smithers son it was so good at
oral sex he could do it on a Floyd
clothed man shot Oh Ned Wong black
dingus
dingus about 15 minutes is passes okay
add five sins for throwing a narration
over halfway through this damn movie
also instead of trimming some of the fat
down from earlier in this movie
Tarantino decided it would be better for
him to just tell us what happened
instead of writing more dialogue Captain
Chris Mannix found the dead generals
code that is inexplicably without bullet
holes and bloodstains even though he was
shot wearing that code 15 minutes
earlier yeah Mannix who apparently
worshiped general Smithers is totally
fine that he's dead and is acting like I
never happened
Bob enjoy demands Anna Roja calm down
Quintin
Russell really smashed up an antique
guitar from the 1870s right there that's
Jennifer Jason Leigh legit freaking out
the sin is not telling Kurt Russell
about the guitar we're not stopping the
scene to switch out the replica or using
a priceless antique in a guitar smashing
scene in the first place this Lewin way
there holy Sh that hasn't been slowed
way down already I don't think I could
make it through the rest of this picture
now many like just about everybody but
she showed don't Magnus but why is it so
that Warren could one day solve a murder
Agatha Christie style that's such an
oddly specific prejudice which just
happens to play into the hands of this
plot even though mark we shoot senior
Bob in the belly at the blood spatter
comes out below his shoulder getting
shot in the dick again so Channing Tatum
is underneath the floorboards what took
him so long to start shooting fools
there were plenty of chances when he
could have killed John and anybody else
he wanted before got to the scene all
right I did it
there was hardly a reason to keep the
hoop boys and the coffee thing a secret
if one of the guys was just gonna admit
it at gunpoint
it was some pretty cool sleuthing going
on there for a bit eliminating all the
people who couldn't have done it but
this review is as satisfying as finding
out there's new Transformers movie
coming
nearly two minutes of a stagecoach
driving to minis that we already know
let's see some faces let's give some
names at no point during this scene does
many supposed he 'tried of Mexicans
surface not even a dirty look it's real
nice of Jo Ann doll for Judy a
peppermint stick but it's odd that he
would reach out his right hand then
magically have the peppermint sticks in
his left hand when the shot changes to
over Judy's shoulder moody steals the
dead man's view shot complete with
Michael Madsen and uma thurman's body
double from Kill Bill and he's gonna
have my sister with him Neve is gonna
have any change that this guy learn
about who captured his sister and when
they were gonna come through here during
the next four hours Jodie and the boys
took the bodies down the well
unnecessary narration is more
unnecessary than usual Jodie is the only
one who lies even though they're all
relatively well known gangsters which we
find out later and with the passengers
in the now arriving stagecoach
propensity for recognizing people it
sure is super fucking lazy that they
don't know who these guys are
tarantino abandons its chapter numbering
scheme i guess he does this to keep
people from leaving the theatre because
they aren't sure how many more chapters
they can endure ah you fell in the
basement wait a minute why didn't Joe D
use his advantage to shoot Chris through
the floorboards to his big bad cat were
fifty thousand dollars and every member
of his gang were released in yeah you
mean to tell me that this professional
bounty hunter guy didn't recognize
anybody from the infamous gang until
Daisy brought up a real last name and
John didn't either surely they'd seen
drawings of some of these people before
any good gun slinging frontiersmen
should know that if someone already has
the draw on you it's probably not the
best idea to jump up and fling your
chair and try and shoot them they will
definitely shoot you first
when the hangman catches you yeah hey
this seems like a weird time for mark we
used to get all sappy and decide to
honor John Ruth can't we just shoot her
and be done with it ah these two
jackasses managed to find the strength
to lift Daisy even after extreme blood
loss so the next person to come across
this stagecoach stop will stumble upon
like $100,000 with the corpses lucky
them hopefully they don't try to drink
from the will
well that's a very offensive way to put
it
you shouldn't say that neighbor girl
don't you know the dancers like being
called nudists you a marina quicker and
Joe good that's my job and please you're
gonna stop your ass to death fat dewayne
swimmers treat their ladies $8,000 a lot
of money for it number this man rate
instead of a gummy partner up with you
I've been hit that is one dog head huh
they just never did get him run water
head today you joined the wall to keep
gutters and chains but no more reasoning
to give Iger
a run for the trees 37 white men for one
hamster what's so hot tree accused you
of being a keel crazy teacher
towns did y'all sack it cause wind
climbers are scared bounty hunters and
broke a friend in the stable
he's got her Bonnie Hunt a friend is
stable minor in this stable hasn't been
in the stable do you know that Hitler
just ain't anymore
inform it soldier Baker tell the tanker
that I don't acknowledge bankers and
northern uniforms and least of all
northern makers you are just some random
boxes old you picked on a pile of
letters you really think the murmured
least of all that lawyer come on come up
here to do a little knock ahead honey
just cut off go first it is saying a
different tune when they found myself at
the mercy of the plumbers done I had the
son of the bloody killer of Baton Rouge
you shut your lying Tiger grabs up he's
just a snaky barber trying to get you to
go for that gun ignoring the critter who
killed your boy you're a real imagine it
that writer you intend to murder me
based on a far-fetched dinner theory how
close you came to being tossed on a pile
of pillows and when it comes to that
piling pillows building out back
you sure picked the wrong time to turn
to a vector don't you see that
genres put you smack dab in the middle
of danger you're about to be murdered in
some code ever a minis house what's
gonna happen when that Sun comes out
vampires
thanks for you Chris shoot that chopper
dead I'm just gonna kill you and that
gamer then shoot that lobsters soon
still own that barber
ladies bison fighting that sock kicks
a wizard is never late Frodo Baggins no
never
forever ever forever ever when John Ruth
the hangman catches shit you don't have
no bullet in the back tiny catch
snowflakes on your tongue it's fun
you've got a letter from Abraham Lincoln
yes B Abraham Lincoln yes Abraham
Lincoln but why you just asked me the
same question at three different ways
normally both your assets would be dead
as fucking fried chicken but you happen
to polish bottom in a transitional
period and I don't want to kill you I
want to help you we seem to be made to
suffer it's our lot in life I've got to
rest before I fall apart
my joints are almost frozen